le sud du québec s'est réveillé dans la
brume
ce matin on aurait dit qu'un voile
enveloppé la métropole j'ai jamais vu ça
de ma vie
à montréal c'est ça fait un peu bizarre
le ciel est un peu plus obscurs et
genevois ne voient pas très clairement
questionner justement comment c'est fait
exprès c'est intense hier la luminosité
est étrange un panache de fumée
provenant des feux de forêt qui font
rage dans le nord ouest de l'ontario
s'est déplacé jusqu'au québec
si ce qui a causé l'épisode de ce mode
qui a touché plusieurs régions du sud de
la province de l'outaouais jusqu'à
québec en passant par le grand montréal
du jamais vu depuis 2013 si rare qu'on
un événement qui avait comme sa poche un
large 1 de la province les grains
territoire comme ce don est pas là je
fumais des fois bien nous visiter et
froid ils font juste resta ne touche pas
la qualité la fois proche du sol la
qualité de l'air s'est aussi détérioré
dans le sud de l'ontario et dans
l'ensemble des provinces de l'ouest en
raison des feux de forêt qui se sont
déclarés un peu partout au pays
le smac fait référence à une pollution
atmosphérique plus importante que
d'habitude
c'est un mélange toxique de gaz et de
particules qui peut s'avérer
potentiellement dangereux pour les plus
vulnérables
j'accélère les problèmes de chanter pour
ceux qui changent et le fragile alors on
va voir les experts d'hospitalisation
sexuelle de défait les aînés les
personnes aux prises avec des problèmes
cardiaques et les asthmatiques sont
particulièrement à risque
quand on est fragile on reste à la
maison comme elle fermera et puis on
quand on est sorti on évite les xerfi
trop violent à succès personnel en
excédent
tous les ans et surtout sa 20 milliards
de dollars de soin de son empire
selon environnement canada l'épisode de
ce mode qui touchent le québec devrait
être terminé d'ici demain on pourra
respirer un peu mieux ici olivier
bachand à radio canada montréal